[Music]
the mainland of China experienced three
outbreaks of SARS between November 2002
and May 2004 the first outbreak resulted
in a pandemic and caused huge financial
loss and social panic but rigorous
policies and control measures that were
established circumvented further
pandemics such efforts control SARS
outbreak
however these outbreaks revealed many
problems in the health system and in the
public understanding of emerging
infectious diseases today the world is
facing another devastating pandemic
whose origins are similar to the SARS
outbreak of 2003 more than 45,000 people
have lost their lives in a matter of few
months and the whole world is currently
in a state of fear and anxiety let's
look at some of the important lessons we
should have learned from the SARS
outbreak of 2003
on 16 November 2002 an outbreak of
severe acute respiratory syndrome or
SARS began in the cordon province of
china chinese government remained silent
and discouraged expressed from reporting
on sars and didn't pass any initial
findings to its own people or even to
the World Health Organization the
response from the rest of the world was
very slow and for the 774 people who
eventually died of SARS it was too late
like SARS in 2003 doctors are accusing
the Chinese government of suppressing
vital information about the global
pandemic we are facing today the world
is criticizing the underreporting of
cases and late intervention by the
Chinese government we all have a right
to access the information about health
care the nature and level of a health
threat and how to protect ourselves
China's irresponsible actions have
severely impacted millions worldwide
[Music]
even though the w-h-o issues advisories
on a regular basis to countries on how
to prepare themselves for a global
pandemic in most of the countries around
the world there has been a severe
shortage of masks sanitizers protective
equipment even in hospitals where
medical professionals expose themselves
to hazards while treating the sick not
enough ventilators not enough sanitation
not enough equipment is a grim reminder
that we didn't learn these lessons from
SARS 2003 that essential items should be
stocked for use as their need can arise
at any point of time billions and
trillions of dollars are spent yearly by
governments all around the world on
military weapons and war despite
thousands of repeated warnings by
scientists not enough money was spent on
hospitals testing facilities and
research centers now many governments of
the world are regretting not learning
this lesson from the SARS outbreak of
2003
[Music]
in February 2003 a doctor from China
carrying the SARS virus traveled to a
family gathering and stayed at a hotel
in Hong Kong it was later found out that
he spread the virus to all the family
members and to other healthy people on
the floor he was staying who went on to
spread the virus in various other
countries like South Korea and USA in
late 2000 nineteen when the current
outbreak began whu-oh and many countries
issued travel warning advisories listing
countries that should be avoided by
foreign travelers and discouraging
international travel in hopes of
preventing further transmission but it
was being reported that young people in
the United States and many other
countries are taking advantage of
availability of cheap tickets and are
traveling possibly endangering the lives
of millions more I hope you liked the
video you can help us make more videos
like this by supporting us on patreon or
becoming a member on our YouTube channel
by clicking the join button below all
links are in the description below thank
you so much for watching